hello everyone it's finally time again
i'm very sorry about the reverb in this
room this is my new office um i am
very slowly unpacking things and putting
things on walls uh it will get less
echoey over time but right now it's
still pretty empty kind of as you can
see
today we are unboxing
two beautiful statues that was sent to
me by prime one i've had these in this
apartment like peeking up in the back of
like instagram stories and stuff for
probably a month i've been meaning to
sit down and do it but time just kept
getting away from me because december is
always very busy it's now january we are
finally doing it i have a kratos and
atreus statue which is of aldi's deadly
missed armor set and a boulder and bird
statue both of which are the ultimate
premium master line you guys are
probably familiar um if you've been
subbed for a while with prime one
because i uh unboxed the batman who
laughs from them which is like one of my
favorite statues one of my favorite
possessions one of the best things i've
ever seen but they did send me these
ones of course i bought that one these
ones were sent to me and it's very very
cool to get god of war statues sent to
me of course while working
at santa monica studio and i intend to
have this bookcase behind me
mostly be for work-related stuff
so like right now you've got some god of
war books the record um that's a figure
there and then i'm gonna have just like
the two statues down the bottom here if
they fit
i suspect they'll be pretty huge they
are prime one and there are two boxes
for each of them so if they don't i will
find somewhere else to put them um but
i'm super excited let's do it all right
we're gonna start
with kratos and atreus here big
beautiful boys i'm so excited it's so
cool
uh let's do it
[Music]
that might work okay
leviathan axe
all right i'm gonna
not do this um because i think it will
be safer though actually hang on let me
look at christmas
there are three of them hang on
i think i like the middle one the most
they're so cool okay
so it doesn't look like the bases in
here that's probably going to be in the
other box so i'm going to open that one
so that i have the base so i can put the
pieces on the base because it seems like
a safer option
this is the base box
it is much more mid-guardian
oh my gosh all right let's go
assembly instructions i will also use
those
whoa
the ice is so cool
it's like actually shiny i'll show you
guys
oh my god it's huge
wow
this is beautiful also very impressed
with the way that oh has the camera been
sliding up it might have
very impressed with the way that they
package everything um i think i said
this last time i feel like they're so
meticulous about making sure that
nothing ships broken uh which is very uh
comforting let me show you the base
see all this like beautiful
sparkly ice
it's gorgeous
let us begin the assembly
[Music]
okay so i didn't know this until just
now um mamia
actually comes with batteries
uh i don't have any unfortunately and i
don't think they've included any i'll
take a better look i just
i'm trying to sort of maintain things
where i took them out of um
but that's amazing i suspect it's his
eyes
yeah it looks like his eyes glow yellow
and there's a little on off switch
like right on the back of his head
that's so cool the little on off switch
is like built into his like
head bits that's amazing i love that
alrighty you guys
it is done and it is beautiful
i
let me just show you the finished piece
i was gonna say let me before i show you
the finished peach blue why
my gosh um so i do have a couple of
pieces left over we have a second axe
which has a metal plate that would be
positioned on uh kratos's back where
right now i currently have
the blades of chaos and we also have
separate blades of chaos um for both
hands
in case you would want your boy kratos
to be wielding those instead so you can
swap them out i've chosen to go with the
leviathan axe and the shield um and have
the blades of chaos on the back just
because i feel like that's a little bit
more reflective of god of war 2018
of this actual game
my gosh let me flip the camera this
thing is beautiful i'm i'm so stoked so
the first thing that like massively
impressed me
is uh a trace of skin
i mean both of them
but just
the way that the skin still looks human
like it's like it's textured um is some
expert
paint work
obviously kratos with all of his ashes
got that nice gray tone to him
uh but yeah it look it really does look
like real textured skin it's incredible
nice winter vibes here for sure um
texture on the clothes is all incredible
it's like beautiful vivid
paint
this was really cool because you
actually have uh
atreus
stringing the the drawstring back for
the bow i had to basically put the bow
in and actually physically move this
myself it's a cool pose it's a cool boss
and then of course
a big boy
kratos with his axe
and his shield
and his battle ready facial expression i
feel like i made the right choice with a
facial expression that is awesome
oh man it's so much detail
this is this rules this absolutely rules
alana for scale
it is huge
very god of war
in scale and i'm very excited about
mamia's eyes lighting up
how neat is that
yeah i've just got my leftover pieces
here
and uh a couple of leftover heads
in here as well that i might like find
some way to display i'm sure somebody on
reddit has like found some cool way to
display second heads for statues maybe i
don't know but
this thing is awesome but that's only
the first we now are moving on to
boulder
okay
so here are our two folder boxes
very very cool i love even these boxes
like i kind of wish i could display them
um but also realize kratos
is not going to fit in this bookcase the
base is too thick so what i think i
might do
is actually buy a pedestal and find a
place on the floor in here to put him
just to like elevate him a little bit um
but we'll see if boulder fits no matter
what uh i do have a space room that's
gonna look super cool oh my god
hello big boy
oh my god
dude the tattoos look so cool
that's amazing
he's huge all right the base is gonna be
in the other box
ah it's heavy it's real heavy
oh my god
this one
is also huge
and incredible i feel like i probably
want to put them next to each other
that's so cool
okay
oh we have
a base
for balda he's going to look real tall i
think which is going to be extra cool
okay so the camera fell over and i
wanted to just safely get the big pieces
out without worrying about it um this
pose is so cool look how much depth
there is i love that he looks like he's
like leaning forward like if i put this
on the side
look
it's such a cool pose it's so aggressive
i feel like it's such a great way to
like
capture who he is and what he's going
through that's a lot of angst in that
pose
incredible i love it
i'm doing some real guesswork assembly
with this one though because a lot of
the pieces look pretty similar
and you can't necessarily see the whole
base so it's just kind of like
we'll see where it fits
it'll it'll come together i'll be fine
this is the exclusive item that comes
with uh this edition
it's a separate piece entirely so i'll
put that in the bookshelf that these two
didn't fit in and i think probably get
like i'll cost him get a pedestal
display for them i reckon is what i'm
gonna do it should be pretty cool but i
will have to show you that assembly at a
later date probably on instagram or
something
very cool
that's awesome
paulder is done
this thing's pose is my favorite like
you didn't have to do all this with the
bass you didn't
have to have all these extra
guys in here you didn't
you didn't have to do all that but you
did
i also have to physically put these
arrows inside of uh
this guy's face here which is super cool
just everything
reaching forward at me
what a cool pose man i feel like this
one like look i love kratos and atreus
they are my boys
this statue though is probably one of my
favorites in my entire collection
just because of how awesome that pose is
like the whole bass just like being the
sort of swirl towards you and ah it
looks so good from every single angle
this is freaking incredible look at it
ah
obviously
because look at them
both of these are absolutely incredible
they are they are gorgeous i am
so stoked to get to own them i do have a
spot for them right here i'm gonna buy
some pedestals i'll post a picture on
instagram
when i have that part done
for now they're just gonna have to chill
on the floor with me because they are
way too big for the bookcase which you
know i kind of expected to be fair they
are just
both
so freaking cool oh my god a huge thank
you to prime1 for sending me these it is
such an honor i'm such a big fan they're
so well made and so easy to put together
and they just look
so awesome on their own i will leave a
link in the description to where you can
check them out okay that's it i'll see
you guys next time bye